zae michou et oui après des mois
d'attentes c'est bon j'ai fait son temps
semble penser que les stars c'est l'île
de la tentation j'ai tout le temps est
quelqu'un que les agences y alors ils
préfèrent le soir entre dans des salles
et je peux vous dire qu'il ya deux trois
couples officielle il ya plein de coupe
officieux des vagues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez sûrement aperçu cette photo
celle du visage tuméfié d'une jeune
fille d'origine camerounaise elle
s'appelle anna chloé à la 11 ans et elle
affirme avoir été poussé par un élève
dans la cour de récréation de son école
merci à nac laurier d'être avec nos
jeunes collégiennes qui dénonce une
agression raciste et madeleine votre
maman merci d'être là toutes les deux
merci pense alors c'est vrai que ça fait
une affaire incroyable sur les réseaux
sociaux ton post a été commentée tout le
monde a réagi dessus
c'est le 15 décembre dernier juste avant
les vacances tu as subi nombre de chutes
on a vu des photos un miroir qui nous
ont tous choqués allait tomber le temps
qu'est ce qui s'est passé voilà un à
chloé toit
bordoy frein pour commencer
mercredi 15 dans la cour je discutais
avec un des camarades à propos d'un
projet qu'on dessert en chance et un
garçon qui a un il ya quelqu'un qui est
arrivé et m'a frappé et moi dans la cour
comme ça ou c'est qu'il ya quelqu'un tu
connaissais dans l'école oui dans ma
classe c dans sa classe d'accord et tu
avais eu déjà eu des problèmes avec lui
oui plusieurs freins et donc il est
arrivé sans rien dire il était venu
taper ou ici on m'a frappé deux fois sur
internet a fait avec moi il me donna un
coup
comme ça d'accord et il est reparti non
et puis l'a dit un sale [ __ ] et il a
recommencé et c'est mon m'a énervé
je crois je lancerai j'allais le rôle ce
qui m'a fait me suis souvenu de ce que
maman elle m'a dit d'aller prévenir à
l'adulte avant de ressurgir et
j'allais le faire donc je me faufile
entre les personnes et j'ai ressenti des
mains nous pousser sur le dos et puis un
bama j'ai connu un bon c'était dans les
escaliers non c'était dehors dehors donc
tu es tombé et a été poussé dehors parce
que et donc quand l'établissement dit
qualité a été poussée dans les escaliers
donc c'est c'est pas du tout dans le
passé pourquoi ça s'est passé dans la
cour oui bah vous savez moi quand j'ai
inscrit ma fille est en cet été avec la
la le règlement intérieur de l'école que
j'ai signé que le directeur a signé
c'est bien mentionné que l'école et les
placer sous la protection des vies aux
surveillantes pour protéger les biens et
les personnes donc pour moi quand ma
petite me dis que maman m'a poussé je me
dis qu'il faudrait absolument que
l'endroit où elle est en biais des
caméras et quand je demande au directeur
de l'école à avoir des caméras bas ils
m'ont fait comprendre que les caméras au
bout de 24 heures l'espèce les fichiers
se surprit n'y a pas de sauvegarde et je
dis bah c'est une blague il avait choisi
de porter plainte aujourd'hui donc j'ai
porté plainte depuis le jour où il m'a
dit que ses caméras en fait ça alors ça
marchait pas que la langue et est en
cours
l'enquêté est en cours et la petite
était entendue et d'éplucher pas de
nouvelles et je me pose des questions
les bonnes années nous voulons mais
c'est moi avec sa part dont vous savez
bien que je vous ai je n'ai jamais
répondu à ça en plus les mousselines on
a même conviction arrêter avec ça c'est
des must et nous la plupart commencent à
voir des frères ont fait pas ça parce
que les compagnons ont fêté le nouvel an
au début j'ai cru que c'était n'da
qu'excepté parodie même pour se moquer
de zemmour mais parce que la zemmour
pour lui faire un chacun sait alors
alors c'est moi voilà je vous le dis il
a dirigé mot maître gims soutient
valérie pécresse vous parle d'identité
voilà bon après il ya eric naulleau qui
réagit également même booba bien entendu
grand pitre son pupitre que tu as mais
ce qu'il dit sur le fond c'est vrai
apparemment quand vous êtes musulman ça
peut être mal perçu de ce débat n'est
donc à rien de choquant moi je pense que
c'est un prétexte pour taper sur maître
gims parce qu'il est musulman et on le
voit avec ces langues et ensuite ce qui
agace c'est que le mec c'est une star il
fait ce qu'il veut il dit ce qu'il veut
et quoi qu'il dise ça ne changera rien
les gens l'adorent il remplit d'un petit
je trouve ça je trouve ça plaisant de
voir une star qui disent qu'ils
pensaient qu'il s'en fout ça va il a
raison guillaumie la droite dire ce
qu'il veut mais ce que je comprends pas
c'est que c'est un message de paix quand
quelqu'un vient de voir et que te dis
joyeuse joyeux noël nous avons une année
c'est un message de peur mais ça je fais
2 qui de tes fans qui te fait bouffer
confesse que tu es devenu hélas tu en
train de t'énerver contre des gens qu'on
fait que tu es devenu gibbs grâce à qui
grâce aux gens et là tu en train de dire
aux gens ouais m'en voyez pas la bonne
année m'envoyer par ceux ci et quand on
regarde tes clips ce qu'on va mettre les
pieds dans le plat quand on regarde
séville il ya des filles en body lui la
des cigares plein la bouche il aura les
musulmans les frères les frères mélange
pas tout mais heureusement tout sinon tu
fais comme tu fais comme quelqu'un qui a
des couilles tu sais qu'un cac a eu des
couilles c'est qui ce mondial africain
john c'est à dire du jour auront
exactement la raison c'est vraiment do
dans les bonnes
[Applaudissements]
et michon et oui après des mois
d'attentes c'est bon c'est fait son
ensemble alors qu'ils participaient
cette saison à danse avec les stars
michou la pépite du web attendait un peu
plus de sa partenaire elsa bois et je
veux qu'on sorte parce qu'un ami mais
j'arrive pas il faut croire que michou a
transformé l'essai comme il le révèle
sur les réseaux sociaux je suis tombée
amoureuse sûr c'est que les stars c'est
l'île de la tentation j'ai tout le temps
et quelqu'un collet adjointe est alors
il est très tard le soir dans des salles
et je peux vous dire qu'il ya eu deux ou
trois couples officielle il ya plein de
coupe officielle des valeurs moi j'ai
bossé sur certaines saisons mais à
chaque saison il y avait au moins trop
castard charlish leurs danseurs
danseuses je le dis rien super des la
danse et le sexe donc ça va avec donc
c'est sûr que ça se termine on s'est
tenu du
6 gsf à tout faire quelque chose comme
ça ma compagne c'est sûr que quand elle
danse bien adorent danser elle tombe sur
un danseur de folie il va se passer
quelque chose et non plus autour de
tourner ça ne risque est là comme un
moustique
arrivé à la fois
danseur gaulle étoile deux minutes
ça
notre compagnon votre affaire en
l'occurrence ton compagnon alors je suis
grâce aux compagnons n'ont pas menti et
ton compagnon être comédien oui comme ça
donc tu n'as pas dit dans son tournage
mais vraie différence entre embrasser
quelqu'un pour un peu ma wii est passé
huit heures par jour pendant 13 semaines
collet à quelqu'un
fera un choix le choix de renoncer ces
travaux également maire d'auch
lamothe il aime c'est beaucoup foot et
il est au cinéma c'est pareil et la
proximité avant tout les gens mais toi
tu la même fatigue le même truc qu'on se
lève tôt on répète les textes on tourne
toute la journée mais ça on s'en fout
mais ces patrons seul le cinéma la danse
et persan ça c'est pire elles sont des
voies vertes et rouges et
ses petits alizée michelin et tout ce
qu'on sait pas mais choses étaient tous
les deux célibataires ils ont
les messieurs à l'arrêt plus non mais on
descendra l'a rompu
c'est à bâtons rompus
et on va revenir sur cette polémique et
pour en parler nous allons recevoir
juliette briet vous savez à les
influences eu ce patriote voilà c'est à
dire guitare et chante la marseillaise
je voudrais pas y est allongé enfin
ta gueule elle s'est indignée des propos
de raymond la première fois que ça mais
je comprends exactement ce que vous
vouliez dire par là je comprends que
vous vouliez mettre en lumière les
incohérences de maitre gims et on peut
même moi ça me fait marrer mais le
problème justement c'est que je pense
que vous prenez pas la mesure de vos
mots quand vous dites ça c'est que vous
dites diam's elle au moins elle a eu les
couilles le courage c'est pas qu'elle
nous avait visé mais lloris dans les
deux sens entre les gens de d'être une
bonne musulmane elle est bas elle a
ruiné sa carrière elle s'est voilée de
la tête aux pieds elle est partie en
arrêt mais saoudite la cousine la
couscous hier tout le tralala et vous
vous trouvez ça génial et tout le monde
sur le plateau applaudit donc qu'est ce
que vous êtes en train de dire aux
jeunes femmes de confession musulmane en
france aujourd'hui pour être une bonne
musulmane et avoir la légitimité de
paris avoir révélé sur la liberté
aujourd'hui c'est bien joué de sa part
mais médiane ce qu'est ce qui est arrivé
à diam's est heureuse dame solide sipa à
célébrer moi quand je vois ça ça me
terrorise juin par une carrière ruinée
j'ai dit à des partis quand elle était
au top en quoi j'ai parlé de karine et
j'ai jamais parlé d'arabie saoudite vous
me parlez d'arabie solo mais ce que l
état d je vous ai parlé des coupables
bon j'ai pas parlé d'arabie saoudite non
et vous avez dit un truc vous dites
c'est terrifiant moi ce que j'entends de
terrifiant ce que vous avez dit
expliquez-moi couscoussière c'est quoi
le couscous ya
c'est vrai que ça c'est toujours à
tiques de dire allez article c'est ce
que je me sépare les deux
îles
alors activés pour me dire les propos de
raymond choqué voilà ce qui me choque ça
fait un pas dix secondes que vous êtes
là sortent à peine du maquillage et des
pépites au vous parlez que
oui on sait
la
juge de vivre est ce que diane ça mais
un camion devant chez vous tous les
matins pour empêcher de vivre c'est l
envie de vivre sa vie laissez la vivre
sa vie arrêtez de les traiter de
couscous hier en
salle
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas bien
tu dis tu es patriotes thème la france
puisque tout c'est ton pays il n'y a pas
de problème mais ça reste quatrième avec
plaisir moi aussi j'aime la france on
leur explique moi on est tous terme
c'est traître se dérangent puisque
raison de plus assez barré en arabie
saoudite a les mêmes tu là ah non elle
est revenue oui je trouvais ça très bien
le dire toi même cas là on a la
meilleure
chez vous maintenant qu'elle est érigé
les bons points des français normaux
gims il a des convictions ils les
expriment ils pratiquent la religion
musulmane comme il en a envie
foutez lui la paix remettez vous l'êtes
pas le juge ne vais pas vous avez qui
aimait bien
séduit
3 et son amie juliette ou cette fille
gilles excuse moi pour chien un mâle
droit de donner son avis sur les membres
de la société a le droit de donner son
avis excuse-moi question est pas leurs
mots tu commences à me gonfler pas qu'on
[Applaudissements]
l'ait important
comme tous les deux là il est gonflé et
alors ça fait quoi arrête de
développement car on redoute qu'on met
en page 6 196
pas sûr
et
guillaume genton vous avez en votre
possession un document incroyable vous
allez voir c'est quoi c'est le procès
verbal de crise tant que ça n'a
franchement rien en tout cas très bien
d'enquêté voyez il ya isabelle qui
regardent et guillaume qui enquêtent
safa regarde on a 5 infos exclusives sur
christian quesada guillaume c'est un
truc de fou vous avez des nouvelles
ouais alors la première info c'est en
dehors du procès verbal et beaucoup de
gens qui se demandent où et christan
quesada il a été aperçu il ya quelques
semaines ammann be any way à
villefranche sur mer dans le sud de la
france à villefranche sur mer dans le
sud de la france il était seul dans une
petite rue étroite pas loin d'une école
une ruine ouais une rue étroite et il
avait l'habitude de se rendre dans le
sud de la france christian quesada
puisque le 27 février 2019 lorsque la
police a essayé de l'arrêter une
première fois il n'était pas chez lui il
avait été aperçu localisé sur la
croisette à cannes pour l'été dans le
sud de la france aperçu à quelques
semaines d'accord première information
deuxième information donc le procès
verbal de christian quesada le jugement
qu'elle était sa motivation à parler à
des mineurs garçon et fille sur internet
voilà ce qu'il répond je voulais
fantasmer avoir des conversations sexuel
le plus possible pourquoi avec des
mineurs parce que les réseaux sociaux
sont plus fréquentées par les mineurs
j'ai un problème avec la tranche d'âge
15 21 ans je suis plus à l'aise à parler
avec des mineurs qu'avec des gens de mon
âge voilà donc ça premier élément du
procès verbal un des arguments de
défense de quesada aussi c'est qu'il
n'est jamais passé à l'acte or on se
rend compte d'un procès verbal que c'est
faux en fait il avait donné rendez vous
à une jeune fille à travers une fausse
identité ou savait qu'il avait des faux
comptes où il se faisait passer pour de
jeunes adolescentes et l'adolescente
avait dit à une jeune mineure est-ce que
ça t'intéresserait de coucher avec un
homme de 50 ans pour 200 euros un homme
qui a gagné aux 12 coups de midi donc
récent quesada la jeune fille accepte
christian quesada fixa rendez vous donne
un lieu de rendez-vous un hôtel près de
la gare de lyon la fille refuse
finalement de se rendre au rendez vous
sauf que problème christian quesada lui
s'est rendu sur le lieu du rendez-vous à
deux reprises à l'hôtel donc le juge lui
dit mais vous vouliez passer à l'acte et
finit par reconnaître que oui il s'est
rendu sur le lieu du rendez-vous à deux
reprises donc ils avaient l'intention de
passer à l'acte même si ça n'a pas lieu
on a deux autres infos on est juste
revoir dans le documentaire on découvre
aussi cette histoire folle qui date de
2001 une plainte avait été déposée à
l'encontre de christian quesada il avait
montré un magazine pornographique un
enfant de 11 ans dans un parc regardez
sa défense pour cette plainte est
complètement folle regarder le show
qu'on regarde aussi fou que cela puisse
pas aux policiers qui vont l'interroger
christian quesada explique s'être tout
simplement tromper d'interlocuteur
il va justifier le fait de se promener
avec un magazine porno en disant qu'il
allait le vendre à un collectionneur et
que bon il a imaginé que c'était ce
petit garçon
j -louis ce qui est fou c'est le trou il
ya 2001 2003 où il a à des plaintes
contre lui il est condamné à du sursis
il ya eu un manque de suivi de la
justice qui est reconnu aujourd'hui
c'est hallucinant la justice ne
reconnaît jamais aujourd'hui elle
procureur qui dit oui il ya eu un trou
il aurait dû être inscrits vraiment au
fichier des délinquants sexuels pour ne
pas récidiver donc c'est le manque de
condamnations lourdes et de suivi à
l'époque qui a occasionné tout ce qui
est arrivé après quand je pense qu'il a
gagné beaucoup d'argent de ce que me dit
et là forcément ça fait plusieurs années
qu'ils ne touchent plus d'argent ces
gardiens qui vit avec le rsa encore
avant le jeu et dans le procès verbal
dont il parle de ses finances
ouvertement et que le juge il dit j'ai
gagné six cent mille euros 12 coups de
midi il nous reste soixante dix mille
euros sur mon compte j'ai offert trois
cent mille euros à mes enfants acheter
un studio à 30000 euros à béziers prêter
80 mille euros à mon frère le reste je
les dépenses et en voyage donc il ne
reste entre guillemets que soixante dix
mille euros à creissan quesada il a
dépensé cinq cent trente mille euros sur
les six cent mille
et rizzi moore pourrait ne pas avoir ces
parrainages pour 2022 comprenez vous qui
parlent de scandale on aura une vidéo
exclusive eric zemmour dans un instant
qui nous a fait juste pour tpm et merci
de me proposer de réagir dans votre
émission était pmp ce matin sur europe 1
j'ai signalé le problème démocratique
que pose le système des parrainages
comme vous le savez pour être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
la loi impose de recueillir 500
signatures d'élus mais ce système de
parrainage a été perverti par françois
hollande car désormais les noms des
mères qui parraine un candidat sont
systématiquement rendu public la
conséquence est simple de nombreux élus
subissent des pressions ils ont peur par
exemple que la région leur retire des
aides pour leur commune
cette loi ne remplit plus son rôle elle
ne sert plus qu'à museler les candidats
qui ne sont pas issus du sérail
politique mais je considère aussi qu'il
n'est pas normal que marine le pen ou
bien jean luc mélenchon et des
difficultés à obtenir leurs parraineurs
c'est un déni de démocratie est une
violation du principe d'égalité des
candidats je demande aux français qui
regardent votre émission trouvez vous
normal qu'un candidats crédités à près
de 15 % dans les sondages représentant
des millions de français ne puisse
finalement pas se présenter parce que il
lui manquerait 500 signatures je tiens
également à le marteler haut et fort je
ne serai l'otage de personne et ne
participerait à aucune combine
politicienne c'est pourquoi j'en appelle
à l'association des maires de france
dirigée par david lisnard monsieur
lisnard vous devez vous saisir de ce
dossier et créer un recueil de
signatures qui sera allouée aux
candidats crédité d'au moins 5% des voix
dans les derniers sondages vous
permettrait ainsi à chaque français
d'être représenté dans cette élection
présidentielle donc il appelle david
lisnard président des maires de france
quand il dit la gelée coup la vidéo
comme vous quand il dit je ne vais pas
rentrer dans des magouilles dans des
voies là et je vais je serai l'otage de
personne derrière ne veut pas il veut
pas de voir quelque chose à quelqu'un
derrière je pense que c'est ça le rend
ça y est alors c'est complètement ambigu
parce que comme maintenant il à touche
touche avec enfin si vous permettez
l'expression avec valérie pécresse il
s'appuie trop quoi faire parce que d'un
côté soit il le laisse se présenter et
effectivement quand il était à 12 13 et
que valérie valérie pécresse était monté
au c'était intéressant parce que ça lui
ouvrais la porte du second tour parce
que le pen descendez mais comme là il
est remonté il ya une ambiguïté parce
qu'ils savent plus maintenant s'ils
doivent l'aider ou pas avoir les
parrainages
hier soir le sénateur du rassemblement
national des bouches du rhône stéphane
ravier était l'invité de ruth elkrief
sur lci
vous m'entendez madame al krief
positiver sur la presse polémique du
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui avait déclaré la veille avoir
très envie d'emmerder les non vaccinés
cela fait quatre ans qu'ils nous
emmerdent lui même nom matinée stéphane
ravier avait été placé à l'écart des
autres invités sur le plateau merci
stéphane ravier d'être avec nous
sénateurs elle ce rassemblement national
hier on vous a mis à l'écart oser dire i
fé dégage franchement ils achètent un
véhicule l incroyable image mais vous le
saviez vous pas que vous avez prévenu
alors oui oui je les confirmés
sur le plateau il ya sur m'avait on
m'avait prévenu que l avec toute la
politesse nécessaire c'est pas madame
elle cria fait qui m'a appelé mais un de
ses collaborateurs pour me faire savoir
que n'étant pas vaccinés comme je
l'avais déclaré à l'occasion d'un
premier entretien et bien et bien on me
mettrai à part on mettrait à l'écart
pour sécuriser les invités sur le
plateau lors je note que l'on m'a pas
mis à l'écart lorsque j'étais dans les
coulisses on n'a pas trouvé
dangereux que j'approche delà de la
maquilleuse que j'approche d'autres
invités c'est uniquement sur le plateau
alors peut-être que c'était pour
protéger surtout madame elle criait si
si c'était un radier avait été d'un
autre parti politique est ce qu'il
aurait été mis à l'écart comme pour son
nom et j'espère sans
préciser à la fois lui le parti qu'elle
redouble friterie sur les joues de la
suite du rassemblement national et je ne
suis pas oxydée s'il fait rire le sol et
s'est mise en scène est ridicule parce
que appartement où tout le monde prend
ses précautions effectivement vous avez
fait un test pc un test avant de venir
voilà vous êtes ici avec nous sur le sur
ce plateau on a beaucoup débattu de leur
moi là on a tout à fait le test il faut
arrêter là pour le coup ça devient
n'importe quoi je pense pas que ce soit
ruth elkrief qui prime
dj wiwi la chaîne un
grand nom syrie le cas mais je pense
qu'elle peut
non je refuse ce plateau sera grotesque
qu'elle aurait pu s'y opposer elle l'a
pas fait
copenhague le doigt qui fait ce qu'il
veut non pas du tout non mais oui tu
écris est si la direction du lit écoute
probable arabe a été créé en plus élevé
qu'ailleurs mais je pense qu'elle dit
bah oui bah ce mec là bas mais oui des
amis m'ont dit mais tu n'aurais pas dû
rester sur une déclaration était avec la
politique de la chaise vide est la pire
je ne mets pas vexer mise parce que j'ai
pas confiance parce que j'ai pas envie
parce que c'est mon choix raconte
moi je soutiens
donc vous n'êtes pas d'anti backs suis
pas d'anti match c'est celui que vous
suivez toujours accès depuis depuis que
depuis que je suis né mais celui-là je
le sens pas cela n'a pas envie et donc
vous allez faire quoi plus de
restaurants ont coûté jeffrey livrés ah
oui c'est vrai film adapté je suis un
sous citoyen je n'aurai plus les mêmes
droits que les 50 autres millions de
français je suis un sous citoyen je suis
traité quand même pas rien alors j'ai
moins de droits que les autres parce que
je ne veux pas être vaccinés c'est une
république vaccinale
à prendre une très très mauvaise
nouvelle puisque igor bogdanoff nous a
quittés il ya un instant on vous dira
tout ce qui s'est passé parce que cette
histoire folle on a perdu grichka il ya
quelques jours igor vient aussi de nous
quitter on aura l'ancien agent d'igor et
grichka extract monde aura pierre jean
pierre lançon qui était très proche
d'eux vous racontera tout ce qui s'est
passé puis à toute cette histoire au
tour du valat de la vaccination pas
vaccinés vacciner on vous parlera de
tout ça mais en tout cas ce qu'on peut
vous dire c'est qu'on est très très
triste parce que igor et grichka y
faisait vraiment partie de la famille
tpm pic vraiment c'était vraiment la
famille c'est comme c'est comme s'il
était un petit peu des chroniqueurs
guest dans cette émission on a fait
énormément de choses avec eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]